The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today and next
time we're going to talk about
psychopathology--
people whose minds, brain, and
behavior are atypical more
often than not.
But we'll talk about
this in a moment.
These people face struggles,
difficulties, and huge goals
to try to help such
individuals.
So we'll talk a little bit about
the history of ideas in
psychiatry and psychopathology,
a little bit
about the ideas of diagnosis
and labels.
And I'll do a little film of a
patient with schizophrenia.
But there's an intuition in some
places and some lives are
led that psychopathology
is rare.
Here's a list of not
all psychiatric
diagnoses but some of them--
schizophrenia; bipolar
disorder; depression;
substance abuse (drugs and
alcohol); anxiety; panic
disorder; phobia; developmental
ones like
autism, ADHD, and dyslexia;
obsessive compulsive disorder.
Tomorrow, I'm reviewing a lot
of research grants for
anorexia and bulimia.
So if we take this list that you
just saw and heard and ask
how many of us in this
room know somebody
that we care about--
could be yourself,
could be a family
member, could be a friend--
know somebody who is touched
by one of these diagnoses?
If you're willing to put up
your hand, who's touched?
Look around the room.
Right?
An incredible number of people
are touched by this.
And so it's a terribly important
topic to understand
and to help individuals and
families who are struggling
with these things.
And in fact it's estimated--
we'll talk about these labels
exactly-- that about half of
all individuals, at some moment
in their life, will
qualify, men or women, at least
for a brief period of
meeting some psychiatric
disorder.
It can be rare and
devastating.
Like schizophrenia--
1% of the population worldwide,
typically
devastating in its
consequences.
It can be potentially milder
like depression which ranges
from very severe to somewhat
moderate and, interestingly,
occurs considerably more often
in women than men.
And we'll talk about
that next time.
There was a recent survey done--
a public health survey,
5,000 young adults, half of them
in college like you, have
them out of college.
They surveyed them and
talk with them.
And about half qualified to have
some sort of psychiatric
disorder within the last year.
Whether they were in or out
of college didn't make a
difference in this study.
But fewer than a quarter of
those who met some criteria
went and sought help.
So how through recent history
have people thought about
people who behave differently,
who are so depressed they
can't get out of bed, who hear
hallucinations, who behave in
agitated ways, and
bipolar disorder?
And it's as much a history story
and a story of culture
and tolerance and intolerance
as it is anything else.
And so unusual or mad behavior,
behavior that's very
disturbing, and atypical--
now there's debates
about all of this.
And so, for example, some
people have argued that
everything that we call
psychiatric disorders is
nothing but the labels we give
to behaviors that we find
uncomfortable or unproductive.
OK?
It's nothing but that.
It's just variation.
Some people are taller
and shorter.
Some people like vanilla
or chocolate ice cream.
And some people do or do not
have bipolar disorder.
All right?
It's a label that's
given for just
variation in human ability--
and we'll talk about that--
or human performance.
And there's many consequences
of that.
Others think that there's
a humanitarian need to
understand the disorders
to help people.
So as you think about these two
sort of perspectives, you
can think that when people
behaved very unusually--
I'll show you a picture of this
that we think some time
ago that people would literally
trephinate, that is,
make a hole in the skull of
individuals to attempt to let
out the demons.
That was the interpretation
of the time.
There's a thought that the witch
hunts in the 16th and
17th centuries, the Salem trials
in the United States
may have involved patients with
things like Huntington's
or Tourette's.
People didn't know how to
interpret unusual behavior.
And so label it as possession
or label it as witchcraft or
something like that.
Insanity began to be understood
as some sort of a
disease but without any approach
to treating it or
helping individuals.
Basically, the process was to
segregate individuals away.
And you would have very large,
pretty scary institutions with
people literally chained and
living in filthy conditions.
There was nobody to care
or protect for them.
In a London zoo you could go
pay a penny and watch the
humans in the cages.
They had not as many visitors
as are in London now for the
royal wedding.
But they had 96,000 in 1814.
It wasn't a rare thing to go pay
your penny and look at the
scary people.
More recently we understand
there's an organic illness and
a psychological illness.
And we'll talk about all that.
But all this is a huge point
that how we understand unusual
behaviors and people is
tremendously influenced by the
historical context
that you're in.
And we'd like to think we're
making progress on this.
I think we are.
But a generation from now people
might look back and
say, how sad that in 2011 people
at MIT were teaching
stuff like this.
Right?
Because if they were that wrong,
how certain are we that
we're that right?
So one has to be a little
cautious about very strong
positions on these
things, I think.
Here are skulls that were
discovered with the
trephination and some evidence
that the person actually
survived this kind of radical
neurosurgery.
But you understand at the time
when somebody behaved very,
very unusually, people had tried
to explain what's going
on and tried to do
what they can.
Here's pretty monstrous looking
devices, heads in
boxes and things kind of like
this, where people were trying
to treat, if you want to call
it, or control individuals who
were having very unusual
behaviors.
Here's a huge hospital.
It had thousands
and thousands.
The name of the hospital
is Bedlam.
And that's what led to the
word bedlam now, more
generally used for sort of
wildness or craziness.
And paintings like this one from
Goya showing a madhouse.
Because at that time, don't
forget, when people-- there
was no drug treatment, no
behavioral treatment.
People were behaving
in scary ways.
And they were sort of put off
to the side to be out of the
range of disturbing
other people.
Now the first step towards
teaching psychiatric diseases
turns out to be a
giant misstep.
But it took a long time for
that to be understood as a
giant misstep.
This is Egas Moniz who did
something that all of us as
scientists would be happy
to have happen to us.
He won the Nobel Prize
in physiology
and medicine in 1949--
the pinnacle of scientific
respect throughout the world.
And he introduced what's now
called frontal lobotomies or
prefrontal lobotomies as
a treatment for severe
psychiatric disorders.
And then in the United
States, Freeman and
Watts picked it up.
And they went around the country
taking basically ice
picks, going inside,
and making various
cuts inside the skulls.
By 1942, there were 5,000 people
per year worldwide
documented, probably
more than that.
These were cases.
And we now look at it
as a terrible idea.
But at the time, this is
all they could imagine.
And that seemed better than
putting people in boxes or
cages was to attempt
to treat it.
And even a kind of a nascent
understanding that very
unusual behaviors went
with something
to do with the brain.
We now understand these front
frontal lobotomies or
prefrontal lobotomies, surgery
to sever the connection to the
frontal lobes, as not treating
the disorder but simply
sedating and controlling
individuals.
When you made a person who was
very agitated, hard to deal
with, hard to control, hard
to reason with, you give a
procedure like this, all of a
sudden they were easier to
deal with for the doctors and
nurses and family members.
And that seemed like progress.
And we now understand that
simply making somebody behave
in a sedated, controllable
way is not what we
mean really by treatment.
But we'll come back to this
in a minute because many
individuals who get medications
don't like to take
their medications.
Some of you may have
that experience.
They feel they're dulled
down in many cases,
not themselves anymore.
And so it's a really tricky
issue at what level some
medications start to approach
that same issue of just making
people behave in ways that other
people find comfortable.
So a nice example of this or
challenging example of this is
from your book where there's
a guy named Ray.
He has Tourette's syndrome.
So we classified that as a
neurological disorder but has
a sort of psychiatric pieces.
You know Tourette's syndrome.
If you don't know from your own
life some way or another,
you know it from movies.
And TV shows love Tourette's
syndrome like law shows with
courts because what do patients
with Tourette's
syndrome do?
They have involuntary
physical tics.
And part of what they have is
they, during those tics, they
curse in pretty horrific ways,
in an uncontrollable way.
So that's ideal for television
plot lines.
It's unbelievably hard for the
children and adults who have
it because they're often
perceived as being scary and
dangerous if they're not
in a controlled state.
So here's a guy named Ray who
has tics every few seconds
since age four.
Imagine if you haven't been--
maybe some of you have gone
through this or know somebody.
It's very tough on children to
have that problem, tough on
adults but really tough
on children.
By the time he's an adult,
he's a weekend drummer.
He loves to play ping-pong.
But he's not doing too well
in terms of jobs.
He loses his jobs
all the time.
And his home life is
pretty miserable.
He has a pretty miserable life
at work and at home.
He tries Haldol which is a
drug that can help with
Tourette's.
And what happens to him?
Is he instantly cured
of his tics and the
happiest person around?
Have any of you glanced
at this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Life seemed
to slow down.
And he keeps trying to
do things he used
to do with his tics.
And he hurts himself,
because his eyes--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
it's slowing his--
he feels slowed down.
Exactly.
So he comes back with a black
eye and a broken nose.
So now, in a controlled,
voluntary way he
curses at the doctor.
And he says, like just trying
to go through a revolving
door, his timing is so off
that he injures himself
because the drug has changed,
in some sense, who he is.
And he feels that.
He's not himself anymore.
He stays on the drug
for three months.
It starts to work.
Over the next nine years
he has a steady jobs.
His familial relations
improve.
He's successfully treated
by sort of
every objective measure--
happiness at home with your
family, holding a job, the
sort of two practical things.
But he likes to live
a life as two Rays.
On the weekends, he likes to go
off his medication and be
himself and be the fast drummer
and ping-pong player
that he enjoyed for
his early life.
And then he'll take the
medication and be the sober,
slow, somewhat sedated
individual who is valued at
the workplace and that can
work things out with this
family more easily.
It's always this interesting
thing about how you're
changing people in order
to help them.
And then, what's that line
between changing them to fit
in versus helping them?
So what is abnormal?
And we mean in a very
statistical sense here, just
being at the tail end
of distributions.
Some things we value being
abnormal, at one end of the
distribution in terms
of success in life.
So what's a mental disorder?
It's a clinically significant
behavioral or psychological
syndrome or pattern that occurs
in a person and that is
associated with present distress
or disability or with
significantly increased risk
of suffering death, pain,
disability, or important
loss of freedom.
So when I talk with
psychiatrists-- and I
collaborate a lot with
them on research--
they emphasize, again, the
functional consequence.
Can you lead a happy
personal life?
Can you lead a reasonably
successful professional life?
And that's almost the
most important
thing beyond anything.
And there's amazing stories
that make you think about
sources of apparent madness
or insanity.
And a powerful story for me is
the story of Semmelweis.
So he noticed, as a physician
in 1840's, that the rate of
death of childhood fever in a
ward served by physicians was
four times as high as mothers in
a ward in the same hospital
served by midwives.
At that time practically every
physician was a male.
And every midwife
was a female.
But you were four times
more likely to die.
That's a big increase in his
death if you were in a ward
that physicians served
compared to midwives.
So he wondered what
that was about.
And he tended to know,
furthermore, that the deaths
tended to occur in women
serially who were in one bed
next to the other.
There were physical
clusters of these.
And so he began to think, well,
for example, if the
priest comes to give the last
rites to this person, does
that psychologically discourage
the next person?
And he also found out that
didn't seem to tell the story.
And then he asked, was
the same doctor
going from bed to bed?
And the answer was yes.
It makes sense, right?
Bed to bed, the same doctors
going down the line of women.
And what he began to notice is
that the physicians we're
reluctant to wash their hands.
Now this sounds ridiculous.
But this is 1840 medicine.
And when he asked them why they
didn't wash their hands,
which we would now consider
pretty fundamental in a
medical environment.
The basic response was
that it was unmanly.
Like, men didn't wash
their hands.
I'm a doctor.
I'm a man.
I don't wash my hands.
I'll come back to this
in a couple minutes.
So he asked them to wash their
hands in a solution of
chlorine and lime.
The deaths fell from 12% to
about 1% in 15 months.
All right, many lives were saved
because the physicians
simply washed their hands and
did not carry infections from
one person to another down the
row of child-bearing women.
1848--
there's a revolution
in Austria.
He's fired from his job.
The doctors--
you would think this would be
better world-- but the doctors
immediately are happy
they no longer have
to wash their hands.
And the death rate goes
right back up.
Joseph Lister in 1880 figured
out the formula of Listerine.
But Lister--
what was going on in terms of
cleanliness and sanitation.
Semmelweis in Austria
becomes crazy.
He runs around to people in the
street, telling them to
wash their hands and
avoid physicians.
And he dies in a mental
institution in 1865.
And imagine if you were
walking here.
And sometimes when you do walk
on the street, you run into
people with psychiatric
difficulties.
And it can be a bit scary.
Imagine somebody runs up to you
and tells you, God sakes,
avoid physicians and please
wash your hands.
Most of us would shrink
back a little bit.
It would be unusually slightly
scary, right?
But is he-- who's the
crazy person, right?
And he's tragically feeling
that if he could just tell
doctors to wash their hands, he
would save lives that day
and into the future.
So but more recently there's
a compelling story for
checklists.
I don't know if any of you
have seen this book.
So in an emergency room-- you
think, OK, that's 1840.
But now we're modern-day USA.
We know what we're doing and
doctors do and other
professionals wash
their hands.
More recently there's a best
seller, couple years ago about
checklists.
So this is what's done
in emergency rooms.
And you may know that there's an
unfortunately high rate of
errors in hospitals, even
among highly skilled
physicians in the best of
academic hospitals.
There's just miscommunications
between doctors and nurses,
changes of shifts, and so on.
Mistakes happen.
And they began to use, as an
experiment, a small checklist,
like five items.
Did you do the following five
things about the catheter or
replacing needles or so on?
And almost instantly, there
was opposition from the
physicians.
They said, we're doctors.
And some of this was at Johns
Hopkins which is, as you know,
a famous academic place.
But I think it would apply
at every hospital.
We're doctors-- now men
and women doctors.
OK?
We don't need a checklist.
I went to college.
I went to medical school.
I've been through
my residency.
I got my specialty
and my boards.
I don't need a checklist.
That's for the intern, right?
So they really opposed it.
But they got almost instantly
far better results of safety.
And including saving lives
almost instantly from the
checklists.
But the physicians still
don't like it
because it seems childish.
So even to this day, it's a
bit of a challenge to get
professionals with pride to do
certain things that go against
the grain, even if it helps
people's health.
So, again, we talked about that
some people think that
mental illness is nothing but
labeling that which we find
unpleasant or difficult,
non-conforming, or deviant.
On the other hand, there's
two things.
One is-- again, so many
hands were up.
I think if you're around it, you
know that for many, many
psychiatric diagnoses there's
a lot of misery involved for
the patient, for the family.
It's not just a conceptual
argument.
And then for many diseases,
like for schizophrenia for
example, in very different
cultures around the world the
rates are strikingly
similar around 1%.
We'll talk about disorders like
autism and ADHD where the
numbers have gone up.
But in schizophrenia, for as
long as people have roughly
had a definition, around
the world is roughly
1%, which is a lot--
1 out of 100 for a very, very
severe, life-altering disease.
So the challenges of diagnosis
are huge because no brain
disorder for all these
neuropsychiatric disorders
that affect so many people can
be spotted by a blood test or
a brain image.
None, zero to this day.
Everybody's working on
it for many years.
And that corner may turn.
Or a genetic test--
none.
So everything is a discussion
between the physician and the
patient and the family.
Everything's a discussion
like that.
You can use your common sense
and do a good job.
But there's risks.
So here's a famous study
that psychiatrists
get really mad about.
I'll tell you, OK?
And you'll hear why
in a moment.
So this is David Rosenhan, a
psychologist at Stanford.
And what he did is he and his
graduate students became
pseudopatients.
They pretended to hear voices,
which is one of the signal
symptoms of schizophrenia,
to hear
voices telling you things.
And of course if you go to an
emergency room and say you're
hearing voices telling you to
do things, you get admitted.
You get a psych consult.
And then what they did is once
they were admitted into a
psychiatry ward, they just
became themselves again.
OK?
But now they had the label that
they had a behavior at
the check-in at the moment of
admission that look like
schizophrenia.
Seven of eight of these people
were diagnosed as
schizophrenia by the
physicians and
nurses who saw them.
And it took them anywhere from
three weeks to two months to
be released.
And every behavior they did--
like taking notes because
they were doing it for
the research paper--
they were frequently interpreted
as another sign of
their disorder like abnormal
writing behavior.
And if they got a little bit
better they would say
schizophrenia but now in
remission because, you
understand, once you have that
perspective on somebody then
every behavior can be
interpreted as a momentary
abatement or, if you're sitting
there scribbling
something, unusual
writing behavior.
So one pseudopatient described
that he had a close
relationship with his mother but
was rather remote from his
father during early childhood.
During adolescence and beyond,
his father became a close
friend while his relationship
cooled with his mother.
OK, so that happens, right?
His present relationship
with his wife was
characteristically
close and warm.
Apart from occasional
angry exchanges,
friction was minimal.
The children had rarely
been spanked.
This is what he told them.
This is the truth.
Nothing's remarkable in
this story, right?
OK.
But because you're a health
professional who's now trying
to figure out why did this
person hear voices, the notes
were this white 39-year-old male
manifests a long history
of considerable ambivalence and
close relationships which
began in early childhood.
A warm relationship with his
mother cools during his
adolescence.
A distant relationship to his
father is described as
becoming very intense.
Affective stability is absent.
His attempts to control
emotionality with his wife and
children are punctuated by angry
outbursts and, in the
case of children, spankings.
I mean, this is human.
This is not--
OK?
Because once you have a take
on somebody, you keep
connecting the dots.
And while he says that he has
several good friends, one
senses considerable ambivalence
embedded in those
relationships also.
OK, you understand that
the interpret--
and you could say, but this
is just the problem of
psychiatric diagnoses--
all discussion and
interpretation.
Finally, they were remitted.
Patient resumes writing
behavior, oral fixation.
It's a little too good
to be almost true.
But there's some stories where
other patients were skeptical.
One patient said quote,
"You're not crazy.
You're a journalist
or professor--
referring to the continual
note-taking.
You're checking up on the
hospital." As if the freed-up
up patients.
Now this is a little bit of a
fable because this makes a
psychiatric disorder sound like
we have a better sense of
reality on the world.
And I don't think anybody thinks
that in a deep way.
But it just shows you how
far off the health
professionals were.
So you tell this story to
psychiatrists, and they get
really mad at you.
I mean, it's a true story.
It shows you the difficulty
of diagnosis.
The psychiatrists I talk with
say, well, they could fake any
disease they wanted to and go
pretty far because if you know
the medical symptoms and you
go and tell doctor those
things, a non-psychiatric
disease, you could get pretty
far in terms of treatment
before they figure out
something's not there, if
you know what to say.
So they just think it's
nothing specific about
psychiatry.
But, in any case, diagnosis--
so what are the criteria for
diagnostic categories?
Signs are what the examiner
sees in symptoms, what the
patient says.
And a syndrome is a cluster
of signs and symptoms.
Everyone neuropsychiatric
psychiatric disorder is
basically a syndrome.
It's a cluster of things that
tend to go together.
But individual patient,
individual patient, individual
patient, shows a different
picture than other people.
They want diagnosis that can
be relatively reliably
assessed, consistently
assessed.
Some sense that there's
some validity to this.
But all of this is sort of
thinking things through.
And then finally all these
thoughts are organized by
experts meeting in hotel rooms
around the country in
conferences.
And they produce a book called
the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of the American
Psychiatric Association--
DSM-IV.
DSM-V is about to come
out in a little bit.
This is the official
list of diagnoses.
These are the lists that all
doctors use, school systems
use, health insurers use.
You have to meet the
criteria in this
book to get a diagnosis.
It looks like that.
People like to point out that
if you pile up the original
DSMs with each version, the
lists get bigger and bigger.
All of these lists are debated
in various ways.
Let me give you a sense of
a couple of the ones.
And you can see the
ambivalence and
the dangers of this.
So psychiatrists in the Soviet
Union, before the Soviet Union
fell, were thrown out of the
worldwide psychiatric
associations because they
would regularly diagnose
protesters of the Soviet Union
as being crazy and had to be
put into mental institutions
and given anti-psychotic
medications because only a crazy
person would fail to
recognize the correctness of
Marxist principles in the
Soviet Union and the
incorrectness of all other
competing systems.
All right?
Now that's what we consider to
be politically abusive, in the
worst sense.
I think some of that is thought
to go on a bit in
China still and other
countries.
But it was manifest in
the Soviet Union.
So that we can throw
out as really bad.
But it just shows you that the
dominant powers in a culture
could make these decisions.
About 20 years ago, if you were
a homosexual, you had a
diagnosis in this book as
a psychiatric disorder.
On a lighter side people--
not always lighter
side, maybe--
people would have debated
whether video game addiction
should count as a
real addiction.
People debate all the time.
What is the borderline between
addictions that almost
everybody agrees in terms of
alcoholism and drug dependency
count as full-scale addictions
versus other things.
What would it take for a person
not to leave the room
ever playing video games to
count as an addiction?
There's debates now in autism
spectrum disorders.
They're about to eliminate
the separate
listings of two diagnoses.
One of them called Asperger's
which is sort of the milder
form of autism, in general.
They're about to eliminate
that distinction.
Many patients and families with
Asperger's don't like that.
And also something called--
here's a bad label--
PDD-NOS, pervasive developmental
disorder not
otherwise specified.
Imagine if you have a child
with difficulty.
And the doctor tells you,
your child has pervasive
developmental disorder not
otherwise specified.
That's a child, basically,
who has two of the three
components of a diagnosis
for autism.
So why draw the line there?
And so psychiatrist, I think,
reasonably are saying, we
don't really understand
the lines.
We're going to call
all of these
autism spectrum disorders.
But you could see these things
are shifting over time.
These labels move as people
think about things.
And there's no definitive
evidence one way or the other
besides best attempts by
people to figure out
what's going on.
And not everybody agrees.
Also--
I'll talk about this
next time--
when one DSM switched to
another, for example, the
number of children in Germany
who qualified for ADHD
diagnosis doubled overnight
because the diagnostic
criteria changed.
That doesn't mean that the--
which is the better one.
You couldn't even begin
to prove which
is the better one--
the original or the one
that had admitted more
children into it.
So these are tough calls.
And you could say, well it's
all kind of a little bit
arbitrary and a bit
subjective.
And it's true.
On the other hand, you've
got to help people.
So why have these labels if
there's all kinds of issues?
Well first, allocation
of resources.
If a person usually needs such
a diagnostic label to get
services at school, to get
medical services in hospitals,
to have insurers support them,
and that's independent of the
kind of medical service
you have.
Right?
Second, if you have a label
that's somewhat useful for--
that helps you know what kind
of service is needed,
different services are needed
for a child with ADHD versus
an adult with depression or
an adult with obsessive
compulsive disorder.
Different things are needed.
A label is needed to even
begin to figure out
which way to go.
And then people also want to
understand a little bit what
can they predict about the
future course of that person--
a little bit of treatment and
their fine, a lot of treatment
and monitoring needed?
You have to do something
practical.
And the labels help you organize
around that with all
the risks of these labels.
So we're going to focus a little
bit on schizophrenia.
And I'll describe
it a little bit.
And then we'll see a film.
So sometimes the word
schizophrenia is used in kind
of a medically incorrect way
which is like multiple
personality disorder.
That's not what schizophrenia
is.
It was described by Bleuler
as a splitting of mental
functions; disintegration
of emotions,
thoughts, and actions.
About 1% worldwide, another 2%
to 3% have a partial version
of schizophrenia.
Practically for every disorder
there's patients
who meet the disorder.
And there's patients
who come close.
And what that exact dividing
line should be and what the
value of it is is constantly
struggled with.
Similar around the world, a
slight tendency from birth in
winter or spring--
people don't know why
schizophrenia happens.
It makes them think about a
virus as part of the story.
Patients with schizophrenia
are defined as having
psychosis, an alteration in
thoughts, perception, and
consciousness.
The thoughts are disconnected
and loose.
They've unusual beliefs
or delusions, often of
persecution.
Somebody else is possessing
their thought.
They can have abnormal
experiences in terms of
auditory hallucinations, mood
disorders, motor alteration.
You'll see in the movie, it was
a restless, purposeless
overactivity.
Can have impoverished
social function.
For a while, people thought a
really important distinction
of schizophrenia was between
what they called negative and
positive symptoms.
So the negative ones were they
did less of what a person
typically does--
poverty of speech, poor
attention, flat affect, lack
of motivation.
Sorry, that's negative.
And the positive were active
things that people don't
usually do-- delusions,
hallucinations, bizarre or
disorganized behaviors.
Biologically, it's been hard to
show that that's kind of a
distinction that matters.
And so what happens with
patients with schizophrenia,
very mysteriously the clinical
onset in most cases is late
adolescence and early
adulthood.
And nobody understands this.
So typically it's in your
18, 20, 22, 24.
How is that such a psychiatric
disorder waits that long and
not much longer in the vast
majority of cases?
What biological thing is ticking
in a person that will
lead to a psychotic break
with reality?
A huge amount of research
now is to try to look at
individuals who are in their
teens and step in and stop
somebody before they have
a psychotic episode.
The positive symptoms are most
evident in this acute
schizophrenic episode.
Negative symptoms often
predominate in the long run.
Huge variability from one
person to the other.
In terms of outcome, the
outcome often responds
positively to anti-psychotic
drugs.
It's estimated about a quarter
of patients make a pretty
strong recovery.
About a quarter remain
very disturbed.
And about half are going
back and forth,
fluctuating over the years.
So a picture that people will
use is there's premorbid
functioning, and then somewhere
in the late teens,
early 20s some dramatically bad
thing happens, and then
some sort of stable condition
with occasional relapses.
And a lot has to do with the
challenge of individuals like
this taking their medications,
partly being organized enough
to take them, partly again
feeling like their real selves
often is not what the
medicated self is.
You may know the movie Beautiful
Mind with John Nash.
And it's just an example how
psychiatric disorders
challenge people of every
mental caliber.
So he won the 1994 Nobel
Prize in Economics.
And if you've seen the movie--
although it's interesting if
you've seen the movie, also
you could go up on YouTube and
see him talking about the
movie because they sanitized him
somewhat to make him more
popular with the movie-going
public because they made it a
more charming disorder than
everybody says it was,
including himself.
But he had a terrific aptitude
for math, went to the Carnegie
Mellon, Princeton for his Ph.D.,
famous for bargaining
problem and non-cooperative
games theory, came to MIT in
1951 as an instructor.
And then, after doing his
fantastic work that won him
the Nobel Prize, developed
acute schizophrenia.
So why don't we watch
the movie.
Tyler, can we do that?
Let me do this.
So here's a fairly
typical patient.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: I have no idea.
Is there any different rate of
schizophrenia in people who--
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
about the voices, hearing
voices in their head.
But if you--
PROFESSOR: That's a--
that's a good--
somebody who were deaf, would
they hear voices in their
schizophrenia?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a fascinating
question
because I have no idea.
I've never thought about that.
It's rare.
Its combination of the two
are moderately rare,
just numbers wise.
But that'd be an interesting
question.
I don't know.
Any other?
I saw another hand, or no?
OK.
So we know one thing that
practically for every
neuropsychiatric disorder,
there's strong familial
evidence that there's a genetic
component to the
disorder and a big one.
So here are four--
this is a very touching
picture, in a way.
These are identical quadruplets,
four girls, who
all grew up to have
schizophrenia.
Not every identical
twin will do that.
So if one twin has
schizophrenia, half the time
the second twin will
have schizophrenia.
If it's dizygotic, it's
still higher than 1%.
But it gets down to 15%.
But I think people have
rethought this because very
often the sibling or the twin,
if you look a little bit more
carefully, they won't meet
the diagnostic criteria.
But they often have struggles
of some kind, as well.
The lifetime probability in
a first degree relative
is 10% versus 1%.
If one parent is 13%,
two parents 50%.
So all this is lots of
suggestions that there's a
genetic basis.
Concordance rates for
monozygotic twins, for
identical twins, is almost
identical whether they're
reared together or apart--
again, suggesting a very
strong genetic basis.
Being adopted away from
relatives does
not reduce the risk.
Having said that, if it's not
100% concordance, there's got
to be something else going
on besides the
simple genes at birth.
It is higher in urban areas,
areas that we think have more
stress in them.
People have noticed
that often times
when people move cultures--
for example, African communities
in London were of
recent immigres.
They kind of seemed to notice a
higher rate, as well, as if
a big cultural move can
put you at risk.
And so everybody pretty much
agrees that there's what
people would call
multifactorial
polygenic-environmental
threshold model.
That is, there's a lot of
different genes, plus
environmental stressors that
come together in some way we
don't understand.
And you would think that with
the human genome decoded to a
large extent and so on, that we
have some clarity on this.
It's been-- you can
debate this.
And certainly identifying the
genes that put you at risk for
these disorders is a hugely
important topic.
The progress in identifying
certain genes for any of these
psychiatric disorders
has been horrible.
Genes are identified one year
and the next five studies
don't replicate it and so on.
So people at the Broad Institute
across the street
now say for them to believe that
a gene is associated with
schizophrenia, they think you
have to have samples of 10,000
patients with schizophrenia and
10,000 people without it.
What does that mean?
That means there's nothing
like a smoking gun gene--
10,000 to have enough statistics
to support a
difference.
That means many, many of the
10,000 don't have that gene
who have schizophrenia.
If it were one gene, one
disorder you don't need 10,000
people to get a statistic.
You need five people.
So it's been a shock to people
that there's been so slow
progress, given that all the
things they can decode the
genome, to find the genes
that are at the heart of
psychiatric diseases.
And that's true for practically
all of them.
So there's something complex
about genes and environment
and people that far exceeds
their understanding at the
moment at every level.
And so people could be modelled
like this because it
makes us feel better.
And there's something probably
right about it.
There's an amount of stress in
your life that can come up
from socioeconomic risk,
health problems, family
situations.
There's a predisposition that's
genetically based.
And some combination of them
determines whether you
manifest the disorder
or don't.
So we said there's no definitive
biological marker
for schizophrenia, as there
isn't for every other
psychiatric disease.
There's no blood test, no brain
test, no nothing that
definitively tells you if a
person has a diagnosis.
But people have been studying
things that are, on average,
different in brains.
And I'll show you some of the
most consistent findings about
ventricles, about hippocampal
involvement, PET scans.
I'll show you this.
And I'll show you a few examples
in schizophrenia.
So one thing people have
noticed is that if they
compare-- these are
identical twins.
And you can see the ventricle,
the fluid filled space, is
somewhat larger in
the twin with the
diagnosis than without.
That's about the least
specific brain marker
we could ever have.
The ventricle just means
that there's tissue
missing around it.
OK?
It's just this fluid-filled
space.
There should be a
bit more tissue.
It's very far from any specific
biology of the disorder.
And here's the actual twins
with their actual MRIs.
So we don't think it's the
size of the ventricle.
That makes no sense.
But that somehow roughly
correlated over the brain
basis of the disorder is.
And then people have shown--
and these are relatively
extreme examples, post-mortem
samples.
Here's the hippocampus in
healthy individuals.
Here you can see a somewhat
shrunken in patients with a
diagnosis of schizophrenia.
And if you look at those
pictures that are kind of
picked, you could say,
well that's easy.
Give me the MRI and I'll
tell you who has it.
But statistically it doesn't
work that way at all.
There's tremendous overlap in
the size of the hippocampus
between people without a
diagnosis and people with
schizophrenia.
So it's a statistical thing.
People have also noticed the
cellular organization
sometimes looks somehow better
in the typical people than
people with schizophrenia.
Again, a suggestion about
a developmental history
underlying this for
the risk but
without any kind of certainty.
When they've done studies
looking at resting scanning
metabolism--
you just laying there.
This is a PET scan.
It's just where is the
blood flowing.
You can see that this
is a healthy person.
A lot of our blood flows
as we sit there
to the frontal cortex.
And you can see it's kind of
diminished in schizophrenia.
But, again, you cannot put
a patient in and say this
patient has schizophrenia
because many patients will
look like many controls.
But the average can
look like this.
Here's a task now of a
working memory task.
So people see in the
easy condition,
letters are running along.
And every time there's an
X, they push a button.
That's the easy condition.
Here, letters are presented
rapidly.
And every time the current
letter is identical to the one
you saw two letters ago,
you push a button.
So this is harder mental work,
harder working memory demands.
And then here's what you
see in one data set.
So as they're doing this task,
they turn on a lot of frontal
cortex, working memory,
thinking.
You're used to that.
Here's controls--
how much they turn it on,
the front of the brain
viewed from the top.
Here's relatives who don't
have the diagnosis.
And here's patients who
do have the diagnosis.
These are relatives
of these patients.
And take a look at it.
You can see they're growing.
So this is this issue
of is more
activation better or worse?
Well it all depends.
The way we interpret this is for
a typical person, here's
how much they have to push the
pedal to accomplish that
working memory task.
If you're a patient, you
have to push it a lot
more to do the task.
And you still make
more mistakes.
If you are a relative without a
diagnosis of schizophrenia,
you're somewhere in between.
And those relatives are
accurate as controls.
But they perform somewhat
more slowly.
This is a kind of interesting
thing.
And practically every disorder,
if you take the
relatives of people with the
diagnosis, they often look
like they have a kind of a
milder version of that.
But they may have no problems
in their lives.
They may be doing flourishingly
well in every
regard that you could
think of.
But they harbor some
of the same genes.
To be a relative means
to share genes.
And so that can make--
there's something about that
happening here or in some
subset of those individuals.
Practically every study that's
done, if you take the
relatives of people with a
diagnosis, there's some
in-betweenness compared to
people picked in families
without any history
of that disorder.
But what matters is
the boundary.
Right?
I mean, this difference doesn't
matter if this person
is doing well.
This difference is associated
with something that really
makes a big difference
in the person's life.
The question about auditory
hallucinations and the deaf--
this is kind of like that.
But this is people
hearing people.
But one of things you can
do with imaging is ask.
Some patients with schizophrenia
have rapidly
psyching auditory
hallucinations.
Most don't.
Most is every here and there.
But some have it pretty often.
So you can put them in a scanner
and when they hear a
voice, they push a button.
And you can ask, when they hear
a voice is their auditory
cortex active?
At the level of the brain is
it as if they were really
hearing a voice?
And here's the auditory cortex
active in the individuals at
the moment they're
experiencing the
hallucination.
It's real to them because
somehow it's engaging the
auditory cortex that really
hears the world.
That's why it's so powerful.
And it's somehow engaging the
very same tissue by which you
really hear the world.
How about treatment?
So next session we'll
talk a lot about
different kinds of treatment.
Neuroleptics are the most
common treatment for
schizophrenia.
They block--
I'll talk a bit about this--
post-synaptic dopamine receptors.
The drug is fully effective
within hours.
The maximum clinical effect
takes weeks and then the
effect remains after
treatment stops.
A huge problem in schizophrenia
are side effects
of these kinds of drugs.
So early on, you induce a bit
of Parkinson's disease in
patients who never had
Parkinson's disease with these
typical drugs.
Because atypical drugs, they
have their problems.
I'll just focus on the
typical drugs.
I'll tell you why in a minute.
And then later on, this becomes
known as tardive
dyskinesia in about
20% of patients.
That's a lot of patients.
You're producing, by the drug,
abnormal and involuntary
movements-- smacking of lips,
chewing, and tongue
protrusion.
And there's some drugs
that don't do it.
But they have other problems.
And there is evidence that
behavioral therapy can be
surprisingly useful
in schizophrenia.
Most of us hardcore biologists
we thing that drugs
got to be the deal.
I think there's more evidence
than you would imagine that
behavioral therapy or the
combination of the two can be
very helpful for people.
So you may know now--
you wouldn't know this, I know
this because I am constantly
in the fund raising business
as a researcher--
drug companies have almost
stopped working on developing
treatments for psychiatric
diseases.
And they've almost stopped
because it's been so
unsuccessful.
The drugs that were found
were almost always by
happenstance--
drugs that were almost randomly
tried for various
disorders or various
groups and worked.
None of them are rationally
done in any biotechnology
sense or molecular chemistry
design sense.
Practically all of them are
happenstance applications of
quasi-random drugs.
And then people noticed
it helped individuals.
And so in the last 28 years,
where there was much more
rational development of drugs,
it's been spectacularly hard
to develop new drugs for
psychiatric disorders.
And so most pharmaceutical
companies have basically
stopped in the last
couple years.
They've just given up.
We remain optimistic that
everybody thinks they'll come
back into the picture when some
academics produce some
things that look good.
But it's turned out
to be really hard.
And, furthermore, many of the
medications that are effective
have all these side effects,
very undesirable
side effects sometimes.
At the same time, the fact that
these drugs affect the
disorder sort of promoted
various theories.
So once people noticed that
the anti-psychotic
medications, medications that
diminish the psychosis of
schizophrenia, act on the
dopamine system, that led to
the dopamine theory
of schizophrenia.
So you say, well if the drug is
pushing down dopamine and
that's helping people be less
psychotic, then maybe what
that real problem is that
there's too much dopamine
flowing in the brain
of individuals with
schizophrenia.
And that got supported by
studies that if you give
typical people overdoses of
amphetamine, you induce
something that looks a bit, in
a typical person, like the
paranoia of schizophrenia.
And so let's talk about
this idea of drug
action versus disease.
So if you have a headache,
what do you take to help
yourself with the headache?
Ibuprofen or aspirin or
something like that?
Does that mean the medical
problem was you didn't have
enough aspirin in your blood?
Were you "hypoasperinemia?"
No, right?
The aspirin is doing something
else to counteract the
headache, or the ibuprofen.
It's not that you were
short on Tylenol.
OK?
But it treats the problem.
So if a drug treats
schizophrenia by acting on the
dopamine system, does that mean
dopamine was the culprit?
And the answer is probably not
or it's hard to figure out.
But the original assumption that
the way the drug works
gives you a direct insight into
what the cause of the
disease is, people have
pretty much dismissed.
But what drew them to it, of
course, is still these
anti-psychotics.
The way they work is
they block the
receptors that take dopamine.
And, therefore, dopamine gets
catabolized here and is not
used in neurotransmission.
And, furthermore, amphetamine,
which produces a somewhat
schizophrenia-like syndrome in
some healthy individuals, that
accelerates the production
of dopamine.
So that seemed to
favor the story.
But, again, that's sort of not
taken very broadly now.
Again, what favored the story
was the more powerfully a drug
bound to dopamine receptors,
the less drug
you had to give patients.
All of that, you could
see, made people
think, this is the story.
And it may be that dopamine
is a part of the story.
But everybody understands now
that just because a drug acts
on a disease, does not mean it's
treating the disease in
the most direct way.
And now why do patients get
tardive dyskinesia?
Why is it an inadvertent
consequence of treating
schizophrenia, producing
a version
of Parkinson's disease?
It's because the drugs
are too nonspecific.
So we know the ventral tegmental
area in the brain
stem sends dopamine into the
basal ganglia and into the
prefrontal cortex.
Conceptually, what we understand
we're trying to
achieve with schizophrenia is
something like diminishing
something about this pathway.
But the drug can't
just block this.
It also affects the
basal ganglia.
And what Parkinson's diseases
is is a shortage of dopamine
in the basal ganglia.
In the case of Parkinson's
disease, it's because of death
of substantial nigral cells.
But you're producing a
pharmacological version of
Parkinson's disease in the
effort to treat schizophrenia.
Not in all patients, not as
severe as Parkinson's disease,
but a big side effect
in many patients.
And there's other drugs.
They have their problems.
There's almost no drug that's
completely successful and pure
in any treatment sense
for the patient.
Despite that, there's been
a fantastic effect.
We talked about that
when people were
behaving very oddly--
and certainly schizophrenia is
perhaps the scariest set of
behaviors, if you have to pick
one disorder in that way--
then once they began to have
drugs that diminished the
unusual behavior, people were
let out of state and
government hospitals where they
had been sort of secluded
in many ways and not helped
in many ways.
And people viewed this as
a tremendous success.
And I think it is to let
people back into the
community, interacting in a sort
of more typical way, as
opposed to being segregated
in areas that were
often not the best.
But there was a fantastic
consequence, which is now
these people, as you may know,
have no safety net.
They're back in the community.
And if they don't have people
who care for them or follow
them, there are risks
for themselves.
So it's great to give
a medication to
let somebody out.
Everybody agrees on that.
But then if you don't have
a kind of a safety net of
physicians and family and so
on, a person's out on their
own, they stop taking their
medication, who's
there to help them?
So it's a societal challenge
on top of that.
So next time I'm going to talk
about treatments for
neuropsychiatric disorders.
But for just one minute I'll
ask you, do you have any
questions or thoughts about
this whole topic?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I read somewhere that 90% of
schizophrenics [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There's
a fantastic--
the question was, why is there
such a fantastically high rate
of smoking-- which there is-- in
patients with schizophrenia
and bipolar?
So people will use phrases like
they're self-medicating
in some way.
But I don't think there's--
you could make up a little
bit of a story,
but it is very striking.
I don't know a deeper
story than that.
There might be.
But it's very striking.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
One girl said she had a
schizophrenic episode and
started smoking afterwards
[INAUDIBLE]
it made the voices go away.
PROFESSOR: It made the
voices go away?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean there's--
But it's very--
there's a phenomenal high
rate of smoking among
patients like that.
OK, thanks very much.